[Musique]
Je suis un agriculteur réparateur des océans,
je me considère comme une nouvelle génération de
personnes travaillant sur l'océan
essayant de gagner leur vie mais aussi d'aider à
redonner vie à nos mers en cette
ère de changement climatique
[Musique]
et j'ai commencé à grandir  toutes ces espèces
ensemble qui créeraient des écosystèmes
qui seraient résilients au climat
et qui aideraient à atténuer le
changement climatique et c'est là que je me retrouve
après toutes ces années
[Musique]
donc
je pense que le potentiel de nourrir la planète
est réel si nous devions prendre
un  zone de la taille de l'état de washington et
créer des fermes de varech,
vous pourriez techniquement nourrir le monde, donc
ce potentiel
de culture de nourriture mais sans utiliser d'eau douce,
pas d'engrais
signifie que c'est le climat parfait
[Musique]
cuisine
vous